[Music]
you dare enter this house
you
mad flavor Wednesday January 4th coming
at you with the [__] bone of debt and
nothing but heart and balls you
understand me because if that's what you
ain't down at a Wednesday it's not gonna
work out for you you gotta leave the
house thinking today is my lucky [__]
day I don't even need a lot of you
ticket you understand me
we got a podcast tonight 8 o'clock we
got collusive casino this weekend but
that's all time take time take that [__]
today's all about you and how you gonna
make it happen how you gonna go out
there and stab a [__] in the end
it's all up to you I'm over here smoking
some blue cookies from perennial I got a
little [__] skywalk container here cuz
your uncle Joey I'm the man of many
reefers I still got a little baggie that
Ryan gave me were like four [__]
ounces if there's an Apocalypto uncle
Joey's ready for it you understand me
I really want to go to jujitsu but how
to switch my day around I'm waiting for
a [__] call I hate my dignity [__]
up but I can't make jujitsu on
Wednesdays but I went yesterday I got my
ass kicked but who gives a [__] I'm an
old man and I don't give a [__] I'm just
trying to get a little skinnier keep the
heart beating and keep the dick hard
that's the most important thing but the
most important thing is to be focused
and sticking out just cuz I got beat up
yesterday what am I gonna [__] quit
who gives a [__] I go back in there
every day just keep showing up they
don't know nothing and you're [__]
learning all of a sudden one day it all
comes together and there you are may
take two years and make take 20 [__]
years but who gives a [__] you're always
working toward something like me I'm
always smoking reefer I'm very good
smoking reefer thirty years I'd be good
at something you knows that
Republic for a moment that we have at
home right now the government's watching
this but who gives a [__]
take a [__] take a ticket [__] get
online I have many government agencies
watching me they've been watching
I got Scientologists watching me but I
don't give a [__] you don't go Joey
I got a 22 of my [__] pointing
straight at all times come [__] with me
[__] come [__] with me cops up the
oil or get that Brenda what puta
you can see that they make towers put
you to Molly I'm sorry I got a Cuba
flashback there for a second must be
Fidel's [__] birthday or something
but it is please [__] choice they're
off yet these stores they fall apart
they jump up joints but you play with a
minute
no way but nothing I got that skywalk
the chase in this [__] you know some
people have a beer and gonna have a
chaser or I have a [__] joint chaser
who's better than me nobody does a joint
chase it with a ball of debt but that's
what you need in today's [__] society
you need to go out there prepared some
push-ups a protein drink a good [__] and
22 [__] thousand [__] grams of THC
floating through your system so nothing
bothers I don't give a [__] I don't give
a [__] I don't give a [__] I'm just
floating listening to voices in my head
yeah me behind buying me say corny
little something for the Chinese people
I rock with them yang Yang [__]
to you
but that's it let's [__] boat
that was very
[__] Oh fresh from the batch oh my
goodness Mamma Mia as Navajo
look at that huh huh that's the type of
[__] Batman used to have to put a mask
over to breathe out the room I don't
give a [__]
remember that episode we'll [__] the
Green Hornet shot the tear gas
look at that smoke into your world to
let you know I love you [__]
today nobody could stop you understand
me the only one that can stop you today
is you got something beside that you
know stopping me nobody might be a few
bulbs you know who said a few bowls of
this [__] even Superman taps
we're gonna feel you [__]
always strength balls hard that's what
you're all about [__] and that's
right steep Bay whatever his [__]
name is next Friday night he's coming
down we're gonna have a good time and
[__] Cleveland if you're in the
Cleveland area don't forget about me
next week that's a good club over there
Larry's fun [__] City man they always
said Cleveland rocks Cleveland rocks
[__] but that's it and that's
that I always have a nice time sharing
this [__] moment with you [__]
hi come on they come right I come on
here to remind you of your superhuman
[__] powers all right we're all
superheroes we have one [__] power
and find it and they can't [__] stop
you're right that's it and that's that
uncle Joey loves you see you tonight
eight o'clock be there or be square if
not I'll see you Friday at the collusive
casino with my main [__] man
Steve D Simoni telling stories of my
pizzas and [__] my paddle up that
[__]
beside that stay black I have a great
day don't let nobody [__] with you okay
okay don't let nobody [__] would you
dump uncle Joey [__] sack man he said
I'm showing up with a big dick and a can
of Lysol all right stay black